Welcome, Christina Najjar, AKA Tinx.
(audience applauding)
Hi, guys.
Thank you for having me.
I'm so excited that you would grace us with your presence.
Oh my God.
I mean it, I'm like hanging on your words.
Talk about why they're calling you the big sister of TikTok.
I like to give out advice.
I think it's all about sharing information.
And if I have a tip that can save a girl
a couple weeks of agony over thinking about a boy
she barely even dated, then that's a win for me.
(audience applauding)
That's a win for everybody.
That's a win for everybody, exactly.
It's about sharing the information.
Totes.
Whatever you know, I don't know everything.
Lord knows I don't know everything.
But I've picked up a thing or two over over my time, so.
Is it experience that has given you this wisdom
or is it just this innate ability to know?
I think it's experience and you know what?
I actually love asking for advice a lot too.
So I think it's kind of a cyclical thing.
Like I'll ask for advice,
I'll listen, I'll pass it on.
It's kind of a back and forth type of thing.
I totally agree.
And you're about to get your own call in show.
Yes.
Which I am so excited about.
(audience applauding)
Oh, please,
we need this.
I'm so excited.
"It's Me, Tinx", and it's on SiriusXM,
I mean, this is so good.
How are you approaching it?
What are you excited about?
I'm just so excited for this opportunity
to take my relationship with my followers to the next level
because I love making TikToks, I love answering DMs,
but there's something so intimate
about being in someone's ear and also hearing a voice,
the power of just talking back and forth is so powerful.
So I'm really excited for this next step
and to grow with my followers.
They've been there with me since the beginning.
(audience applauding)
I love that.
Thank you, thank you.
But I also just think, how did Tinx come up?
It's so pithy
and like cute and optimistic.
So cute.
You know, it's a funny story.
It's actually a nickname I've had for 20 years.
It's based on a movie character named Tinka Parker
from this little known movie called "Strike"
about an all girl school.
Anyway, long story short,
there was this cool girl in the movie
and I thought, "I wanna be confident like her."
So I started, I went to my friends, I said,
"You guys, you gotta call me Tinka from now on
because I'm like her."
It was my Sasha Fierce moment, I had an alter ego.
Hey.
And you know what?
Fake it till you make it works because slowly, over time,
I just started to become Tinka Parker, this confident girl.
And I've been called Tinx ever since.
I love it, and if Beyonce needs an alter ego,
we all do.
We all need an alter ego,
for sure, for sure.
Well, I love the box theory is about, I mean,
you saw the video, so you know what it's about,
but that really resonated with people.
I feel like you got a lot of response to that.
Like it really did go extremely viral
and people felt passionate about that you were right.
Yeah.
And that people do get put in boxes
and can't get out of them.
Yeah, I think my hope is that it saves people time,
because I get so many messages from girls saying,
"I'm trying to get this guy to date me.
What can I do?
If I talk about how much I love golden retrievers
if I don't hook up with him,
like what will make him wanna date me?"
And I'm like, "Why are you trying to get someone to date you
who doesn't wanna date you?
You're in the hookup box, leave it, you're good."
(audience applauding)
Nothing you do can make someone wanna date you,
nor should it, because someone should want to,
there's a person out there for everybody
who there's no games, it's just easy,
and that's what you're looking for.
(audience applauding)
The simplest advice but it's so true.
It's so true.
Just be you.
And when
the right person fits, it fits.
Yeah, don't try to manipulate your way
into a relationship 'cause those never pan out.
And trust me, I have done the leg work.
(bright music)